[音楽]
あの
買いすぎました
うわああああああああ
den o 2
なんでこうなったらが経緯を説明しますとバーナーをたくさん欲しいなって言った
まぎれもなく僕です30100 the くらい貼ってたくさんバーンあったら
どんどんバナナが一番甘いのかなと思って聞いたでしょ
なんかお店の人に聞いたんですよお店な人に陥ったらなんか
1つ当たり後6本でヒロンてはず言われて遊んナースねって幌
本山ないやん
ai 00られないがー0日本じゃないどっ
沿いはこれおかしいでしょジャズ45おかしいでしょまんまー
本来はない検証の対象の増えただけ僕我ながらこの体力はドンキーコングじゃないから
数バンドドンキーコングのスタートの家の主短編だけどバナーいろんな花とここにある
んですけど
このばそんなの中でどれが一番あまりか美味しいか
糖度が高いか調べていこうと思いますたぶんですね甘いば何だって
見た目でわかるんですよねちょっと調べてみよう甘いパターンの見分け方みたいな
シュガースポット
黒い斑点が多いバナーはやっぱり甘いみたいですねあと
大きい花は美味しいのかなっ張りつんのあいつ
よくわかんない常識的に考えて太くて大きい花楼なう
なんか月に考えて太くて大きい花の方が美味しいらしいです
エロい件増タイで一番甘いバナナを食べると思いますこれだけパンダがあればもう
非常に美味しい答えがいてもおかしくないと思うのでそれぜひ当社の中で一番美味し
そうな花を見つけますそれぞれでその中から一番美味しいやつを選んでいきましょう
ってよ
デブ専ねそもそも婦さんの数のちょっとおかしくて1002あるんですよ
今だいたい数えると12安打25本から銃発砲あるで暑くなく見て15かける100
1500本あります
あああいった
ポッ
ん
はいと夕食各プーさんの代表が決まりましたーーー
はいというわけでこちらが今回の房の予選を勝ち抜いた代表のみなさまでおめでとう
ございまーすはいそしてこちらが今後は予選敗退されるバナナが皆様ですおつかれさま
でしたしばらくそちらの観覧席でしちゃいをご覧ください a 約100婦さんの花
たちが揃ったんですけどもうここからはナンバー1を決めるわけなんで神聖なチェック
が必要なの
こちらの糖度計ば何の正確な糖度を計っていこうと思いますスってあるんだろうまあ
そうですこれで何食べきるソードがせると思うんで載せて何かやれば頭だってるって
言ったやつでしょ代表の負担の皆様の糖度を計ってランマー長さを持つバーン
決めていこうと思います金がナンバー1たらん
[音楽]
やっぱ吠えまってまってまでまず数字見える
夏行きます
[音楽]
ん
おおーー
これ3図1弾でをやっぱすごいの鉄門だろう
ピッ
晴れ
というわけで無事全部の代表の糖度の調査が終わりましたーーー
で時間かかった
[音楽]
itu でで神聖なる藤堂
の計測による結果
ファイナリストちょっと校1キを脱いでる頭角を現して甘かった花たちを呼んでこよう
と思います
ファイナリストの皆様どうぞ
エントリーナンバー24番へとリーダーバー72番そしてエントリーナンバーなら16
番
こちらの3組が本当に朝の数値がぶっ壊れてました
とても高い3組でございますまあ共通点としてはなんかなんだろう
やっぱ多少のシュガースポットは必須ですねちょっと黒くなってるのも必須なんです
けど
それ以上にことにも生かすで回以上にデカイです
ただなんか34番にカーサ小さいだからなんかふとさーんとかまぁ関係なく甘いものは
前のかなっていう気がしましたを最後は僕が食べて判断してみようと思いますでは
30万から
いただきますいただきます
[音楽]
続いては72番ですっております
銀語タイ語76万いただきます
[音楽]
はいというわけで3つ食べ終わりましたもうなんか食った瞬間これ違うだっていうのが
あったんで
もう僕の中の一番決まってます第1回
間違えて彼はデータパターンな選手権は弄ら play
第1話
[音楽]
エントリーナンバーすっ
ナンマンダエントリーナンバー3ぞ4番端までー
いやもうこのビッグタイプの日本差し置いてこっちが経っても美味しかったです
全然コツな場合です
まぁ全部同じなんだけどねえっ
me
バッハ